n'aie pas peur on est des personnes des
personnes normales
je sais que l'inconnu peut faire peur
mais j'espère que grâce à cette vidéo tu
n'auras plus peur de l'inconnu et que tu
pourras comprendre certaines choses on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était très dur pendant toute ma
scolarité que six points 3e seconde
elle me prenait beaucoup de beaucoup de
remarques et du coup à la sama ça m'a
fait me renfermer sur moi beaucoup même
trop et du coup ça s'est passé pendant
quelques temps j'ai eu du coup beaucoup
plus de deux mâles à mourir aux autres
aujourd'hui on vit dans un monde où on
les joue beaucoup et les ventes sur le
physique où les physiques et vous une
place primordiale trop importante et que
du coup on ne prend pas le temps d'aller
plus loin et de connaître la personne
plus loin aujourd'hui de la maladie me
pose aucun souci je suis bien je vis
normalement
du coup à la sait plus ce regard peu
besoin des autres qui peut être huit qui
est on va dire le plus handicapant
parfois on se sent vraiment cerner par
par plein de regard oui donc c'est ça
qui est le plus gênant aujourd'hui ils
iraient dont 20 chez moi pour cet aspect
de la maladie le quotidien céder mes cds
de sursaut et de surprises et c'est même
encore aujourd'hui ce qui m'arrivait
dans mon parcours d'étudiant qu'en fait
un master de la discrimination des
remarques sommes dix ans n'était pas
fait pour une thèse que de faire le
meilleur boulot pour moi c'était d'être
seul derrière un ordi
enfermé seul dans une pièce
[Musique]
j'avais tenu réparé c'est vrai c'est
c'est l'amour de mes parents de mes amis
et surtout leur soutien qui a été
extrêmement important je pense que sont
l'or le soutien j'aurais pu m'écrouler
m'effondrer plus loin et un frère et une
soeur qui eux sont ne sont pas atteints
reçu le seul de la famille atteints et
ça se passe vraiment très bien
il choque c'est que dans dans les médias
dans la rue à la télé ils voient jamais
des personnes qui ont des problèmes au
visage il vous faut penser aussi que ça
va être pas à faire accepter ces
personnes
je pense que le fait que des personnes
en parlent et ose s'affirmer s'est
montrée s'exposer ça peut aussi être un
déclencheur pour d'autres et une prise
de conscience pour fne de redire et ben
la société et les autres finalement né
et le monde n'est pas aussi cruel que ce
que ce que je pense que l'idée que je me
fais et que avec le temps avec l'âge les
perceptions et les mentalités peuvent
pas évoluer